this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah I'm sorry I kind of like trailed
off with my drear updates I think I
posted too but they were pretty
comprehensive but then I just fell into
a hole of insanity because we had a
really really busy er and hopefully this
makes up for it and you can hear about
everything I did between the last step
say that now so um as was said I went to
Australia to pursue my interests in
grapes wine and really relations to
climate change and there will be lots of
animal pictures in this presentation
because I love animals and there's lots
of cool ones in Australia so before I
get into like the nitty-gritty academic
stuff I thought I'd give you some fun
background about other things I learned
in Australia not related to viticulture
perhaps the scariest was how to drive a
manual car on the wrong side of the road
that was terrifying
I am now trying to readjust to the right
side of the road so it's always a
struggle how to live involuntarily with
very large spiders that are very fast
they're called Huntsman because they run
after their prey and they don't build
webs so they are just gone like that I
did play one game of cricket I was told
I did a good job I don't really
understand the rules but they told me
what to do and I did it so I played
cricket check and how to understand
Australians what the heck are they
saying if you can abbreviate a word they
will abbreviate it
if you can't abbreviate a word they will
still managed to abbreviate it and yeah
it's like a completely different
language so that was interesting so I
went to Australia as we know here is a
map showing you the wine regions of
Australia pretty big continent lots of
wine regions I was based right oh no
sorry no laser anyway I was based right
here in this green area South Australia
which is actually producing more than
50% of Australian wine so it's the
largest production area I was right here
in the middle of all this at the
University of Adelaide
smack in the middle of the wine regions
of South Australia and we had research
projects up in the Riverland which is
that yellow squarish area to the
northeast which is very hot very
intensive agriculture high yielding
vines and we had research sites down in
the southeast in [ __ ] awara which is in
that orange region it's a cooler climate
and of course we had work at the
University vineyard in the middle where
the stars one interesting thing about
South Australia is it's a quarantine
area for Phil Ochs row so there are no
Phil Ochs are there meaning that has
some of the oldest find in the world
lots of undrafted vines people still
grab her other reasons but it's pretty
cool to work alongside hundreds of year
old vines there and so I was working
with dr. Vinay Peggy who many some of
you here might be familiar with
absolutely incredible guy his wife Fran
who was an amazing friend to me while I
was there and the rest of his lab who
are all wonderful people from all around
the world and I had just an incredible
experience with them so I'll kind of
break down for you what I did this year
because the drear award was only
supposed to be for the first half of the
year but I was there until last week so
I pretty much had a full year in
Australia and I'll explain to you what
that consisted of so in their summer
fall which is our winter spring here I
was doing the jury reward had a lab
intern so just participating in all of
his research projects all over the state
of South Australia collecting data
analyzing data preparing publications
you name it and I also had a part-time
job with the a WRI which is the
Australian wine Research Institute so on
the weekends during harvest I was
working for them I was making small lot
research wines applying treatments
basically seeing the wines through from
grapes to bottle so that was a really
great experience for me because it added
to my overall knowledge base of
viticulture and enology
and then for the second half of the year
Vinay actually took me on as his
technician and that involved you know
some taste testing of the wines that we
in the places we were working make sure
that everything's ok and I was also
working for the university's research
vineyard as a technician I was doing
lots of practical things like driving
the tractor spraying slashing mowing
repairing irrigation getting those
practical skills under my belt
it was a great awesome experience very
thankful for that and in between it all
I traveled and I saw lots of animals I
travelled some more and I'm really happy
with all the animals I met this year and
my schedule was flexible enough that it
allowed me to do that which was really
great so the million dollar question is
how many projects does Benet have
because any of you who know him know
that he is like just just unstoppable so
passionate about his work and he takes
on everything he never says no so I
can't tell you how many projects he has
even though that was kind of my job was
to know how many projects he has because
almost every week she'd be talking to me
about some other projects that I didn't
know he had and I was like I thought I'm
here technician I thought I'm supposed
to do these things but there are just
too many I can't even count but to give
you a little bit of a sample this is one
of his new PhD students and she's
working on volatile signal signaling for
drought stress in grapevines so it's
starting off as a green house study
that's super interesting then we had I
wrote about this in my blog post once
this is continuous sensing of grapevine
water status using infrared cameras and
that was down in Kenora so he's trying
to develop an index that will correlate
these thermal missed thermal data to
bind water status so I spent a lot of
time helping on that project that
project also involves flying airplanes
with multispectral cameras over the
vineyards which was super cool and we
got to see this airplane
this year in [ __ ] awara he has a new
project on berry cell death and how that
relates to berry shrivel which is a
concern for them down there so this is a
fluorescent microscopy image that I made
of a berry that I sliced and stay and
then we run that through computer
programs to see how much cell death is
occurring so that's ongoing this coming
year he's still got his micro
tensiometer project happening which some
of you may be familiar with which is
that chip that sits in the vine xylem
and monitors water status continuously
as well as he's also working on
hyperspectral imagery or laser
hyperspectral sensing of viruses so
right now we have this backpack
contraption but hopefully he wants to
put this on a drone with the camera and
just get hyper spectral images of
vineyards to detect viruses so that's
just a small sample of Vinay's ongoing
work that i got to participate in which
was great and now i am going to talk to
you about a project that i worked
intensively on active canopy cooling
strategies to mitigate the negative
effects of heat waves on grapevines and
I gave this presentation a few weeks ago
at the crush seminar at the University
of Adelaide and so yeah hopefully it
goes nice and smooth this time so back
to climate change the reason I went to
Australia all over the world obviously
agriculture is going to have to contend
with the effects of climate change in
Australia where most wine growing
regions are semi-arid and Mediterranean
climates we have to worry about the
seasons getting hotter and drier so
we're worried about a few things not
limited to compressed growing seasons
which means hotter shorter seasons a
dual warming effect and most models are
predicting that damage to reproductive
organ development which is the flowers
which send results in our fruit the most
important thing
failure of flamer flavor and aroma
development so a lot of heat can squash
out those compounds that we
for in quality wine and overall water
scarcity across the board so not just in
the culture but all agricultural
pursuits are gonna be dealing with water
scarcity so what can we do because in
the coming decades I want to be like a
world-famous viticulturist so I have to
deal with this right so we have to do
something and even if we stop emitting
carbon today right now even if we shut
off all our cars and stop eating beef
we're still going to be dealing with the
effects of climate change in the years
to come because the climate has inertia
so at this point the best risk
management strategy is adaptation so
here's a graph that I put together of
the historical occurrence of heat waves
up in the Riverland which was that
northeastern yellow area that I
discussed really really hot high
intensity agriculture high yields and
last year 1617 we only had four heat
waves so that's relatively fewer than in
previous years but we only expect that
trend to increase as the years go by so
how do we define a heat wave for our
study for this purpose we define a heat
wave as three days or more of 35 degrees
Celsius or greater and we arrived at
that definition using the Greer and
Whedon paper where they showed that at
that threshold we're seeing negative
effects on vine physiology and wine
quality great ventolin qualities as far
as active canopy cooling goes the whole
point of this presentation there's not
too much in the field on active canopy
cooling in the 70s in California Algebra
II and Gilbert looked at overhead
sprinkling and they did have some
success with that but it hasn't really
been touched since more recently last
year curuvija at the University of
Adelaide investigated in canopy cooling
so misting in the canopy and we actually
have an extension of that project
happening this year that I worked on as
well I'm not going to go into that one
in depth for this presentation but I'm
happy to talk about it with any of you
if you're curious later
so our objectives for this work were to
evaluate the vine performance during the
heat waves we looked at the canopy
microclimate so the temperature the
humidity the vapor pressure deficit and
we looked at the effects on grape and
wine quality so we were up in the
Riverland as I said we were working with
a commercial grower on Savion Blanc
vines for court on sprawl absolutely
huge vines very high yielding and we had
these two trials at the same site right
next to each other the in canopy cooling
trial which was a misting in the canopy
trial that I just mentioned but I'll
talk about later if you want and then
the under canopy cooling trial which is
a special interest to me and that's what
we'll talk about today so the under
canopy cooling trial or UCC had two
treatments compared to control the
control was your traditional drip line
irrigation grower controlled just your
regular drip line the under canopy
sprinklers the first treatment or UCS
were basically broadcast sprinklers that
wet the entire mid row of the vineyard
floor so under the vine in the middle of
the vine everywhere was wet and then the
supplemental irrigation or si was a
bypass drip line that deposited the same
volume of water but directly under the
vine instead of everywhere like the UCS
did it put the same amount of water just
under the vine oh sorry and the most
important thing about these treatments
is to keep in mind that they were on at
night so if we saw a heat wave was
coming up we would trigger the system to
go on the night before and all of the
nights during the heat wave but this
wasn't happening during the day so we
collected a lot of data because Vinay
loves data and I am going to primarily
talk to you about the data we collected
on the caffeine microclimate the leaves
gas exchange and the soil and plant
water statuses but don't worry we also
looked at a lot of other things so that
would take me a long time to go through
but
we have and this is a picture of our NGO
or infrared gas analyzer it's made by
likeor and this machine is was initially
very scary to me but now I'm intimately
acquainted with it and I use it a lot
this year and that helps us understand
the photosynthesis and the stomata
conductance and leaves so here are some
graphs I put together of the temperature
and the vapor pressure deficit at the
hottest part of the day during a
heatwave so this was three or more days
at 35 C or greater this particular day
was over 40 Celsius and this is the heat
of the day and the dot-dash line on the
bottom of both graphs is the under
canopy sprinkler or the UCS so you can
see that the temperature of the UCS
treatment stayed below 40 degrees even
at the hottest part of the day and the
vapor pressure deficit was below 5 kilo
Pascal's and remember that these
treatments were on at night so we're
seeing this effect in the middle of the
day which is pretty awesome in my
opinion and here you see basically more
ideal physiological conditions for
physiological function during this heat
wave in the ucs treatment while the SI
and the control are much hotter and
drier here are a couple of thermal
images we put together so you can kind
of visualize what's happening in the mid
row and under vine in the control you
had a really hot in the drove 45 degrees
Celsius in the supplemental irrigation
it was cooler at 38 but it was coolest
in the under canopy sprinklers at 33 and
the same trend is happening under the
vine as well so now we will go into the
soil and plant water status so top graph
is pre-dawn water potential of my
favorite measurement 3 o'clock in the
morning we go out and we do pressure
bombing which is take a leaf put it in a
chamber put pressure on it and see how
much pressure it takes to make a drop of
water come out and in the pre-dawn that
gives us an idea of soil moisture
content so
creet on water potential correlates with
soil moistures that's why we take that
measurement then the bottom graph is
midday stem water potential which gives
us an idea of the plants water status so
soil water status plant water status and
you can see again mid heatwave in the
middle of a heat wave the control is the
black the supplemental irrigation is the
chequered and the under canopy
sprinklers is the gray and there are no
significant differences in soil water
status across any of these treatments so
we know based on that that we are not
having an irrigation effect with these
treatments the point of this research is
not to irrigate the vines it's to
actively cool them so how can we apply
water so that it has a cooling effect
it's not intended to irrigate the vines
so based on that lack of significance in
the top graph lack of difference in soil
moisture we see no irrigation effect if
you will then we look down at the midday
water potential and we see that the
control is significantly lower than the
two treatments so the control is
relatively water stress during this
heatwave compared to the two treatments
but there are no differences between the
SI and the UCS so keep that in mind
while we move to this slide
so again middle of a heat wave top graph
a n net photosynthesis bottom graph G
ESTs the model conductance and you can
see that the control in both the
photosynthesis and the conductance has
significantly lower rates for both
that's easily explained by the fact that
the plant is water stress as we saw in
the previous slide looking at the midday
stem water potential
but then curiously we see a difference
between the two treatments for both
parameters so we can't explain the
difference in photosynthesis for the two
treatments based on water status because
we saw here that there was no difference
in water status for the treatments so we
have to explain this somehow out some
other way we have two theories that we
will or not we they will investigate
further this year unfortunately I can't
be there
the first being that perhaps because in
the supplemental irrigation the root
zone is very wet it's concentrated
directly under the vine a wet area that
abscisic acid or ABA is being
translocated up from the root zone to
the leaves and closing the stomata down
regulating photosynthesis and stomatal
conductance and that might not be
happening in the ucs because the water
is distributed all across the vineyard
floor
another possibility is simply that the
canopy microclimate in the ucs is more
favorable for photosynthesis and
stomatal conductance in the middle of a
heat wave because we saw that it's a lot
cooler and less dry lower vapor pressure
deficit during the heat wave so that
soil evaporation can just be promoting
overall more ideal conditions for canopy
function during a heatwave so as far as
other results go we saw significantly
higher TA or titratable acidity in the
ucs and si treatment lines so that's
great because we want to preserve
acidity through these heat events loss
of acidity in must or grapes after heat
events is something we don't want we
didn't see any differences in yield but
we can conclude that the ucs treatment
is effectively cooling the canopy and
promoting ideal conditions for
physiological function during heat waves
if you ask me why I don't think we saw
many more results than this this year I
think it's because it wasn't such a hot
year for Australia as you saw in the
first graph there were four heat waves
which is not so much for for this
climate and I think that in future years
when it's hotter and drier and you have
more heat events you might see these
treatments start to separate in other
parameters so yeah that's that's my
theory as to why there wasn't so many
differences this year in this coming
season we're going to they're going to
characterize the route density and
distribution
and evaluate the soil moisture and
temperature since we didn't do that last
year we really don't know what's going
on underground are there roots in the
mid row are they active what is the soil
temperature and moisture in those areas
that can really help us hone in on our
theories as to why we saw those
physiological differences and they're
also going to sample abscisic acid or
ABA at time points before during and
after he wave so we can see if there's
any differences in that hormone so for
this project I'd like to thank wine
australia for their funding Oxford
landing estates was our cooperating
grower they did a great job and lots of
people in our lab and outside of our lab
who helped on this they were awesome and
they really saved Boston and for this
entire experience overall I'd like to
thank the drear committee Nina
Marvin John and I have to thank Fran
Bonet and the whole lab for just making
this year beyond incredible I learned so
much I am so grateful and I can't say
enough good things about the drear award
or about Vinay in his lab because it's
they're just amazing so yeah I'd like to
thank everybody so we were just
yeah sure yeah so I think the question
is about disease pressure with a wet
canopy is that right and you use nets to
cool so shade cloth is absolutely one
option to cool your canopy
there's work on that as we know in
Australia in this very dry climate we
didn't
see any increase in disease pressure
yeah there was really like it was
negligible I think in the Finger Lakes
it wouldn't be possible to do in canopy
misting that would just yet be a
disaster probably here
but in this hot dry climate it's really
not even a concern that's the first
thing I thought when I got there because
I'm I was cool climate conditioned when
I got over there but we didn't see any
disease incidents increase with that and
can't be misting project yeah does that
answer it each night oh sorry yeah yeah
so Connor asked me about how much water
was applied at night for those
treatments and I'm just gonna pull up
that information because I don't want to
give you the wrong answer but I have it
so it is it's a lot of water obviously
but you know our our point is to
preserve or increase the quality
maintain the quality or make it better
going into these really hot seasons that
were expecting uh
so you have to use more water right so
what's the best way to use it
should we just irrigate or should we try
something like this like active canopy
cooling that's that's a valid question
no sorry yeah I'm trying to find this
for you
i calibrated the system before I left
but I forgot so basically the so the
sprinklers turned on for 30 minutes
every hour and a half for a total of
four cycles throughout the night and the
flow rate was 57 litres per vine per
night and then yeah
for the for the whole year in the under
canopy sprinkler treatment the water
application for the season was five
point six mega litres per hectare if you
compare that to the grower irrigation
the grower irrigation is seven point
seven mega litres per hectare so does
that give you some context kind of so
for this under canopy cooling trial so
this is not the in canopy misting trial
that I like briefly mentioned but for
this under canopy trial you can see that
the temperature was maintained
throughout the day for the in canopy
misting which I did not present the data
on the temperature drops very quickly
five to eight degrees Celsius in the
canopy but then it came back up almost
immediately and so this year they're
gonna tweak that and try to their
modeling it and trying to see like what
is the optimal frequency and duration of
misting to maintain the canopy
temperature at or below 35 C that's the
goal ideally so if you find because of
the chemical response just you
mentioning but he get really hot but
something to consider negative effect I
don't think so because when we have
these really intense heat events the
vines are often shutting down right so
they're stopping physiological function
and then you might be losing some of
your desirable components and the grapes
aroma compounds and whatnot actually
when we harvested this trial the
cooperating grower was supposed to
harvest just about the same time as us
but they held off almost a week and a
half to two weeks after because we
harvested right after a heatwave and
they wanted to wait for the vines to
build up more sugar because they had
kind of just shut down at that point so
we're worried about like hotter shorter
seasons and faster ripening we're also
worried about vines just quitting when
it's too hot right
and then loss of those desirable
characteristics and your grapes and wine
during those really high heat events do
you have any questions yeah okay ah hi
Raquel this Tim Martinson yeah can you
comment on you know given the water
shortage and the droughts that they have
what are what is the industry in general
is doing to address the water shortage
are they using different methods of
scheduling irrigation or what what
what's the response been to the drought
in general it's really Oh first of all
first of all last year was actually not
a drought at all it was a very wet year
Australia so while I was there that's
not a good example because they had more
rain in their growing seasons than we
had in our 2016 growing season which is
pretty incredible but I I was pretty
amazed to tell you the truth about the
lack of a consistent response to these
drought events or irrigation in general
you know a lot of our cooperating
growers we're asking vinay like what
what do we do like how do we how do we
schedule like when do we irrigate you
know we go by like touching the leaves
or
visual clues or something right and so
it was really amazing to see that there
is like a lack of knowledge that will
allow them to respond to this and so
that's exactly like what he's working on
right so it was okay it was great to see
that our work is very needed there and
it was really a grower by grower like
everyone had their own response really
turn on their irrigation
I don't know they'll be okay oh the
leaves look a little hot and tilted away
from the Sun maybe we should turn it on
now so it was really not consistent and
you an Australian viticulture and wine
making overall I think is very
technology savvy and they're really on
the cutting edge I think but the fact
that they didn't have a consistent
response was just yeah Wow
like we need this work right really
needs to be done not personally but I
think some people use it
none of the sites that I visited we're
doing anything like that but yeah
there's our di but in terms of people
are really at a loss that's like what
the best route going forward is for
irrigation scheduling and dealing with
these heat events yeah that's that's my
honest perception you know someone
someone could tell me otherwise but I I
heard it for more than one grower and I
was amazed yeah yeah um so I'm not
making this argument but how would you
respond to to this argument that look
climate is getting hotter we're running
out of good water is this really a good
use of our scarce resources and at one
point should we kind of pull the plug on
trying to grow grapes in Australia
anyways and how can we do this more
sustainably longer like what's the logic
there
yeah it's a valid question I mean I'm
not prepared personally to give up my
Australian wine because I think there is
recourse right but I don't know I think
agriculture in Australia needs to
undergo some changes as a whole like
they're still growing rice in this same
region of Australia like that is
ridiculous right having rice paddies in
the outback
essentially so not to be like species
but I would prioritize
grape quality over growing rice in the
almost Australian outback and the whole
point of this is to see you know how can
we do it as efficiently as possible
we're going to need more water but how
should we apply it right and what will
make the biggest difference for our
quality with using the less well the
least water possible is that exactly
thank you there's I don't think there's
like a one right answer for that right
[Music]
so do I do we irrigate the roots to
decrease temperature correct so we so
okay so the question I think was we are
applying water under the canopy to
decrease the temperature of the canopy
of the vines so okay so there were two
like I said before there were two
experiments there was the in canopy
cooling experiment which is misters
inside the canopy and then there was
this under canopy cooling experiment
which was misting on the vineyard floor
right
so it's two separate experiments and
this one under canopy cooling was
applying water broadcast to the vineyard
floor and this one in canopy cooling had
misters inside the canopy does that make
sense yeah it was like it was a sprayer
system in the canopy so Ann wants to
know if we're looking at the route
turnover rate in the under canopy
sprinkler treatment so we actually
haven't looked at anything below ground
yet so this coming year is gonna be all
about what's yeah what's going on
underground because we know almost
nothing about that and that could be the
key to explaining a lot of this same
I'll let you know and they tell me I
don't know about the analysis method but
basically when we are sorry Geneva she
asked me what method of Abyei analysis
were using so I'm not sure about the
chemical analysis of it but how we
collected or we will collect it is is
when we do the pressure bomb so we do
that midday stem water potential and you
have the leaf in the chamber and the
water droplet comes out of the stem
we're gonna pipette that into a little
vial
you only need I think a tiny amount yeah
yeah exactly yeah anyone else you want
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu